this week companies like Samsung are
introducing the first phones fitted with
5g the new generation of mobile
technology that's faster smarter and
more powerful than the current standard
Chinese tech giant Huawei is at the
forefront of 5g securing roll out
contracts in nearly 30 countries notable
exception is the United States which
considers the company to be a national
security threat in his first TV
interview with an American reporter
Huawei founder and CEO Wren Zhang Fei
says the Trump administration's fears
are overblown we spoke with the
company's headquarters in Shenzhen China
you know three she dad - so she in there
they've been regarding 5g as the
technology at the same level of the some
other military equipment 5g is not an
atomic mom 5g is the latest high-speed
mobile innovation promising to multiply
wireless internet speeds and increase
coverage GOG now we are rolling out 5g
and soon we'll welcome six genes and in
the future I said there will be new
equipment that is suitable for the
United States but US intelligence
agencies are concerned about Huawei's 5g
growth it is so much faster and it
allows such a larger data flow that it
significantly enhances the capabilities
of an intelligence service to steal data
former CIA acting director Michael
Morell 5g is going to allow a much
larger number of devices to be connected
to the Internet when you connect more
devices you create more platforms from
which an intelligence service can spy
from the Trump administration has warned
its allies that it may reconsider its
military relationships with countries
that use wall way we cannot ensure the
defence of the West if our allies grow
dependent on the East do you view that
as a threat
well youkai should come in Janka first
of all I would like to thank them
because they are great figures 5g was
not known by common people but now these
great figures are all talking about 5g
and we're becoming more info
intial and getting more contracts I
sense a little bit of sarcasm there
oh please tell them I'm actually
thanking them for promoting us despite
warnings from the Trump administration
some of our European allies including
Germany and the UK are reportedly
considering allowing Huawei to build
their high-speed infrastructure it's
technologically advanced it's reliable
as all get-out and it's affordable some
Americans already rely on Huawei
technology this is Kobe we're in the
middle of nowhere like Mike Kilgore who
runs a wireless provider servicing more
than 11,000 square miles of rural
Montana we've heard of the security
concerns we've heard of the allegations
of connections to the Chinese government
but nobody's ever produced any evidence
related to that as the Trump
administration weighs a ban on all
Chinese telecoms in the u.s. Kilgore is
worried his company wouldn't survive
leaving his community essentially
without service a few did not have the
ability to dial 911 phone I I just I
can't that will that turns my stomach
for Ren despite all the criticism from
the administration
he knows his company's future in America
is in the president's hands
time for President Trump I think he is a
great president because in a very short
period of time he was able to reduce the
tax rate you speak very highly a
president Trump yet he is likely to
issue an executive order banning your
company from doing any business in the
United States how do you square the two
well truth a tikka well we have never
had many sales in the United States but
we didn't give up our efforts in this
country so if you wonder which American
company may be rolling out 5g as well
Cisco is a competitor and they've
announced that they're prepared to roll
out 5g by 2022 the difference is Huawei
saying they're prepared much sooner by
2020 and a lot of industry experts are
concerned that these conflicts may delay
the rollout overall and impact
millions of users but law enforcement
and intelligence experts believe that
they are using this to steal all kinds
of information from us they are adamant
that that whether or not Huawei gives
the government of China permission that
China will find a backdoor to get any
customer data and that is the big
concern but it's it's in the interest of
companies to partner with Huawei because
the faster you can get to 5g the faster
all your customers who want that faster
service will go which is why you're
seeing so many countries around the
world including our allies say thank you
for the warning to the United States
government but we may continue to do
that to do business with Huawei because
it's in our benefit what was your take
on mr. Huawei because he seemed to have
quite a sense of humor yeah he seems
sarcastic in times but he certainly
seemed to be engaged and I think that's
tough to do during trends and when
you're you know when you're
conversations being translated on both
sides look he says he had nothing but
respect for the American government for
president Trump he invited President
Trump to the facility they have a very
impressive campus I met with a lot of
their scientists and a lot of their 5g
experts he said please come visit we
have nothing to hide I have great
respect for America he's been to America
before he'd like to come back and he'd
liked him this was his first
introduction to the American thing he
doesn't speak English he does not so he
seemed to welcome you and also
interesting to see the president the
distance between the president and his
intelligence officers on this not as
much as known some other issues exactly
thank you thank you